since the Disney and Fox deal is
officially done and the x-men can be
used in the MCU one of the biggest
questions is how exactly will they enter
the MCU and since the events of Avengers
infinity war and Avengers in Game one of
the even bigger questions and theories
are did one of the snaps actually create
the x-men how's it going everybody it's
Warren and the writers of Avengers
infinity war and Avengers in game have
actually decided to address this
question in an interview before we dive
into it don't forget to subscribe to my
channel at the 400,000 subscriber mark
I'll be picking three winners to choose
one item from the Marvel Legends series
collection and I'll talk more about that
at the end in an interview with The
Hollywood Reporter Christopher Markus
and Stephen McFeely the two writers for
Avengers infinity war and Avengers and
game were asked if the snap actually
created the x-men and here's what they
had to say anything is possible but I
don't know whether you'd need that
genetic mutation is genetic mutation it
just happens maybe they are already out
there McFeely went on to say I do think
that whenever Kevin decides to do x-men
or Fantastic Four it won't be how you
think it's going to happen I think he's
going to have a real clever version of
it so there you have it according to the
writers they did not write in the snap
creating the x-men into the movies and
they do not think that that's how it's
going to happen when the x-men and
Fantastic Four are finally introduced
into the MCU they said that they expect
that the mutants are already up there
which would make sense because like they
said genetic mutation is genetic
mutation but based on what they said
about Kevin Feige the president of
Marvel Studios introducing the x-men or
Fantastic Four at one point it sounds
like it's going to be in a way that we
really don't expect so that's going to
be really exciting when it happens so it
appears that the snap did not create the
x-men so they'll be introduced in
another way after all spider-man far
from home did just introduce the
multiverse to us so perhaps the x-men
actually exist on another earth just not
our earth but just like Mysterio claims
to have come from another earth maybe
one day we will see the x-men so let me
know your own thoughts about how the
x-men could enter the MCU and again
don't forget to subscribe at the 400,000
subscriber mark I'll be picking not one
but three winners and they'll get to
choose one item from the Marvel Legends
series collection there will be multiple
ways to enter in multiple chances to win
that I'll describe in a video tomorrow
so be sure to sub
grabbed in chat the giveaway and so you
can stay up to date on everything
relating to the MC you drop a like if
you enjoyed the video and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
[Music]